so we have an infinite series here one
plus one over two to the fifth plus one
over three to the fifth and we just keep
on going forever we could write this as
the sum from N equals one to infinity of
one over N to the fifth power one over N
to the fifth power and now you might
recognize notice when N is equal to 1
this is 1 over 1 to the 5th that's that
over there and we could keep on going
now you might immediately recognize this
as a p-series and a p-series has the
general form of the sum going from N
equals 1 to infinity of 1 over N to the
P where P is a positive value so in this
particular case our P for this P series
is equal to 5 P is equal to 5 now you
might already recognize under which
conditions for AP series does it
converge or diverge it's going to
converge it's going to converge when
your P is greater than 1 which is
clearly the case in this scenario right
over here our P is clearly greater than
1 we would diverge we would diverge if
our P is greater than 0 and less than or
equal or less than or equal to 1 this
would be a divergence so if this was
like 0.9 here or if this was a you know
3/4 then we would be diverging so at
least for this one we are convergent
let's do another one of these all right
so here you might again recognize this
as a p-series let me rewrite this
infinite sum so this is the sum from N
equals 1 to infinity of 1 over C we have
a square root of 2 square root of 3 so
you could view this as 2 to the 1 half 3
to the 1/2 4 to the 1/2 so it's 1 over N
to the 1/2 notice this is when n is
equal to 1 1 over
the 1/2 is 1 1 over 2 to the 1/2 well
that's this right over here and we keep
on going on and on and on well in this
case we still have a p-series we have 1
over N to some power and that power is
positive but notice in this case our P
falls between 0 and 1 so 1/2 is our P so
P for our P series is equal to 1/2 and
that's between 0 and 1 remember we're
divergent divergent when our P is
greater than 0 and less than or equal to
1 which was clearly the case right over
here so this is going to be divergent